do you hope would become a
multi-planetary species so we almost
sneaking up to that but um you know the
efforts of SpaceX of Elon maybe in
general what your thoughts are about
those efforts so you already mentioned
Starship will be very interesting for
astronomy for for science in general
just getting stuff out into space
but what about the longer term goal of
actually colonizing of building
civilizations on other surfaces on moons
on planets it seems like an a fairly
obvious thing to do for our survival
right there's a high risk if if we are
committed to trying to keep this human
experiment going
um putting all of our eggs in one basket
is always going to be a risky strategy
to pursue tonight's best good though but
yeah it is a beautiful basket I wouldn't
want to I personally have no interest in
living on mars or the moon I would like
to visit but I would definitely not want
to spend the rest of my life and die on
Mars it's a it's mean it's a hell hole
Mars is a very very diff I think the
idea this is going to happen in the next
you know 10 20 years is seems to be very
optimistic
um not that it's insurmountable but the
the challenges are extreme to survive on
a planet like Mars which is you know
like a dry Frozen desert
um with a high radiation environment
it's it's a challenge of a type we've
never faced before so it's I'm sure
human Ingenuity can tackle it but I'm
skeptical that we'll have thousands of
people living on Mars in my lifetime but
I would I I would relish that
opportunity to maybe one day visit such
a settlement and you know do scientific
experiments on mars or experience Mars
do astronomy from art in all sorts of
cool stuff you could do
um you know sometimes you see these
dreams of outer solar system exploration
and you can like fly through the clouds
of Venus or you could
um just do these enormous jumps on like
these small moons where you can
essentially jump as high as a skyscraper
and Traverse I mean so there's all sorts
of you know Wonderful ice skating on
Europa it might be fun so don't get me
wrong I love the idea of us becoming
into planetary I think it's
um
it's just a question of uh time our own
our own destructive Tendencies uh as you
said earlier are add-ons with our
emerging capability to become
interplanetary and the question is will
we get out of the nest before we burn it
down and I don't know I obviously I hope
that we do but I I don't have any
special Insight that
there is a prop there is somewhat of a
gnoring intellectual itch I have with
the so-called doomsday argument which
um I try not to treat too seriously but
there is some element of it that bothers
me uh the Dooms argument basically
suggests that
you know you're typically the mediocrity
principal you're not special that you're
probably going to be born somewhere in
the middle of all human beings will ever
be born you're unlikely to be one of the
first one percent of human beings that
ever lived and then one of the last ones
and similarly the last one percent of
human beings because you'd be very
unique and special if that were true
and so by this logic you can sort of
calculate um how many generations of
humans you might expect so if there's
been let's say 100 billion human beings
that have ever lived on this planet then
you could say to 95 confidence so you
divide by five percent so a hundred
billion divided by 0.05 would give you 2
trillion human beings that would ever
live
you'd expect by this argument and so if
each
um if let's say each each planet in
general the planet has a 10 billion
population so that would be 200
generations of humans we would expect
ahead of us and if each one has an
average lifetime let's say 100 years
then that would be about 20 000 years so
there's 20 000 years left in the clock
there's like a typical doomsday argument
type
that's how they typically lay it out
um now you can argue a lot of the
criticisms that doomsday argument come
down to what are you really counting
you're counting humans there but maybe
you should be counting years or maybe
you should be counting human hours you
know how what are you because what you
count makes a big difference to what you
get out on the other ends this is called
the reference class
um and so that's when the big criticisms
that doomsday I come in but I do think
it has a compelling point that it would
be surprising if our future is to one
day Blossom and become a Galactic
spanning Empire trillions upon trillions
upon trillions of human beings will one
day live across the stars for
essentially as long as the Galaxy exists
and the Stars Burn
we would live at an incredibly special
point in that story we would be right at
the very very very beginning and that's
not impossible but it's just somewhat
improbable and so there's part of that
sort of um irks against me but it also
almost feels like a philosophical
argument because you're sort of talking
about
Souls being drawn from this Cosmic pool
um so it's it's not an argument that I
lose sleep about for our fate of the
Doomsday but it is
um
somewhat intellectually annoying that
that there is a slight contradiction now
it feels like with the idea of a
Galactic spanning Empire
and but of course there's so many
unknowns
I I for one would love to visit even
space but Mars just imagine standing on
Mars and looking back at Earth
yeah I mean
um the incredible sight
it would give you such a
fresh perspective as to your entire
existence and wanted to be human yeah
and then come back to earth and it would
give you
and give you a heck of a perspective
plus this the sunset on Mars is supposed
to be nice I loved what William Shatner
said after his flight
um his words really moved me when he
came down and I think uh
it really captured the idea that we
shouldn't really be sending uh Engineers
our scientists into space we should be
sending out poets because those are the
people when they come down who can who
can truly make a difference with when
they describe their experiences in space
and I found it very moving reading what
he what he said
yeah when you talk to astronauts when
they when they describe what they see
it's like this
like they discovered a whole new thing
that they can't possibly convert back
into words yeah
um yeah it's it's beautiful to see